so Lauren of course is a uh documentary
filmmaker I mean you want to mention
anything else about your work you're
doing work with tenant media now we're
alled yes I'm with tenant media which
you are as well a very exciting crew
we've got Matt Christensen Taylor Hansen
Ruben Benny Johnson um yeah so you can
go check them out tenet media on YouTube
watch tenet now on the twitters and I'll
be doing videos and little mini docs for
them and hopefully some more
documentaries for you as well but uh
yeah if you want to check out some of my
older film work I've done Farm lands on
South Africa borderless on the migrant
crisis American Mirage uh Crossfire and
now infringed I've got quite the body of
work and the lovely John Dua has helped
me with a couple of those now three of
them three of them now yeah you did
Cross Too did some work on Cross that's
right who are you sir what you do yeah
well I'm John DUIs I'm the guy who's
behind the scenes I'm behind the camera
so it's uh it's a real privilege and
honor for me to be in front of the
camera for once